bonsoir frédéric saint clair merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
quels sont les enjeux on s'attend à pas
de grands bouleversements en tout cas
dans les équilibres la droite devrait
conforter son assise
will et les enjeux cent sont des enjeux
de conservation de déséquilibre en place
historiquement la droite est majoritaire
au sénat
donc on le dit historiquement serre dans
l'histoire de la vème république lé
majeri majoritaires au sénat et le sénat
lui même une institution issue de la de
la droite est une chambre et une chambre
e hôte sse et une chambres
aristocratiques et une chambre où le
mandat était historiquement très long 9
années il a été réduit à 6 années est
aussi une chambre territoriale donc
c'est une chambre qui est censé faire le
lien entre le pouvoir politique et la le
quotidien des français donc c'est une
chambre importante une chambre un
contre-pouvoir au pouvoir législatif
donc incarné par l'assemblée qui en
règle générale du même bord que le
président élu donc là ce n'est pas le
cas la droite et l'air est majoritaire à
au sénat puis c'est un contre-pouvoir en
matière de transformation de la
modification de la constitution parce
qu'on sait qu'il faut une majorité des
trois cinquièmes à ce moment là ne
suffit pas d'avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée il faut aussi gagner une
majorité au sénat et un certain nombre
de modifications que le président macro
auraient anticipé pourrait être bloquée
du fait qu'une droite récalcitrante
est ce que le véritablement ce sénat
joue son rôle de contre-pouvoir que vous
nous décrivez
on sait que les français finalement
beaucoup se disent à quoi sert le sénat
alors qu'il ya déjà là la chambre des
députés le la question est légitime elle
s'est d'ailleurs posé de nombreuses fois
dans l'histoire de de la république
le sepa la première fois j'allais dire
comment ça se déroule sur la nécessité
de garder ou pas ça s'est posé il ya pas
si longtemps que ça et puis ça s'est
posée
moment du départ du général de gaulle
puisque c'était une grande réforme des
régions et du sénat qui aura été
fortement diminuée qui était associé au
conseil économique et social et qui
aurait eu donc simplement un pouvoir
consultatif et plus de pouvoir
décisionnel donc le référendum a été
perdu par le général de gaulle comme
chacun sait et il a remis sa démission
ce sénat est un contre pouvoir en
matière législative c'est-à-dire que
effectivement il est possible pour le
pouvoir exécutif de donner priorité à
l'assemblée est de faire en sorte que
finalement le l'assemblée se comporte
comme une chambre d'enregistrement du
pouvoir exécutif et que la l'equilibre
l'aller-retour les navettes entre le
sénat et l'assemblée ne ne joue pas son
rôle mais en réalité une grande partie
des présidents de la république joue ce
rôle pleinement ce rôle législatif et
donc le sénat a un rôle de
contre-pouvoir et l'amande les textes
qui arrive en commission et puis on a vu
au moment de la sphère benalla à quel
point la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale était soumise à au
pouvoir en place exécutif et donc c'est
de cette commission est passée aux yeux
des français comme une pseudo commission
alors que celle dirigée par philippe bas
au sein du sénat était beaucoup plus
offensive a beaucoup plus fait bouger
les lignes
alors bien évidemment sur quoi quels
débouchés pour l'instant rien mais on
s'est rendu compte que le sénat avait au
moins dans un dans une certaine partie
de son de l'étendue de ses pouvoirs joué
son rôle
comment comment est-ce que vous
expliquer le fait que le sénat soit soit
davantage à droite on le sait ce sont
les grands électeurs qui votent ceux qui
sont issus d'ailleurs des dernières
municipales les élus territoriaux qui se
présente justement pour pour élire les
sénateurs comment expliquer
justement cet ancrage à droite il ya une
mécanique il ya une mécanique qui ce qui
se reproduit et ensuite
alors il ya eu un basculement un 2006
narbonne 2011 2014 je ne pourrais pas
dire de bêtises mais à à gauche mais
globalement la droite est majoritaire
dans le pays dans l'est dans les
communes et qui quand la droite est
majoritaire dans les commissions que les
grands électeurs sont communes comme l'a
dit votre journaliste principalement des
conseillers municipaux et bien
mécaniquement il y a un c'est là qui est
à droite c'est pas une spécificité
française
c'est aussi le cas aux etats-unis c'est
aussi le cas dans d'autres grandes
démocraties la chambre des lords en
grande bretagne est principalement
conservatrice c'est un set d'une chambre
qui incarne quelque part le
conservatisme c'est à dire le le
principe d'une décision politique qui
soit plus réfléchie qui soit plus
distanciée par rapport au pouvoir
exécutif qui soit plus proche des
territoires et donc de l'endroit où se
se fabrique l'intelligence et le concret
de la vie politique et donc on sait que
ces territoires sont majoritairement aux
ruraux et on a aussi la une forte
implantation delà de la droite comme on
a pu le voir lors des dernières
élections municipales donc il y à un
terreau plutôt favorable pour cette
chambre que je continue de qualifier
d'aristocratique parce que c'est
vraiment ce qu'ils avaient l'autre enjeu
est évidemment minime mais c'est la
place qu'obtiendra évidemment là la
république en marche on sait qu'ils ont
pas beaucoup de sénateurs également les
verts qui pourraient faire leur entrée
au sénat
alors oui effectivement les verts qui
ont déjà quelques quelques membres qui
sont 5 je crois
dont elle à esther benbassa qui est qui
est relativement médiatisé est donc
connue des français il pourrait gagner
un certain nombre d'autres sénateurs et
donc être être présent heller omc le
sait le vrai enjeu en fait pour le pour
le président emmanuel macron ancrer son
parti au delà de sa personne dans une
politique et laisser une empreinte
durable imaginer qu'il soit battu aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
il pourrait on pourrait imaginer que
sont l'assemblée nationale bascule du
côté du nouveau président s'il n'y a
aucun ancrage au niveau du sénat ce
l'empreinte qu'il a laissée aurait été
vraiment de courte durée ce nouveau
monde aurait complètement disparu dont
ancrer ce sont sont son travail
politique sa façon d'envisager la
politique dans la durée ça suppose
d'avoir des parlementaires à l'assemblée
nationale n'est pas seulement donc
d'avoir aussi des élus terrain dans les
municipalités on a vu le faible ancrage
de l air m pendant les municipales il ça
suppose aussi donc de facto d'élargir le
socle des sénateurs dans la durée il est
fort probable que ça que ça se passera
pas et que l erreur qui est déjà présent
au sénat avec gaza un socle relativement
faible avec 23 sièges effectivement
quid du rassemblement national de
députés deux sénateurs étaient entrés en
2014 précisément ont ils des chances d'y
rester côté c'est toujours compliqué le
rassemblement le rassemblement national
a du mal on le voit a brisé un double
plafond de verre le premier qui est
électorale liée au scrutin direct et qui
concernent directement les français
c'est à dire donner l'image d'un parti
qui est capable d'arriver au pouvoir et
de gérer au delà de la question
migratoire l'ensemble des problématiques
politiques du pays et donc de prendre en
charge à la fois les inquiétudes des
français mais aussi
la gestion de l'appareil d'état et puis
le deuxième plafond de verre qui est
davantage une ligne rouge c'est
d'arriver à convaincre pas seulement les
français mais les autres élus dans le
cas du sénat s'est particulièrement
délicat parce que même si le votre est à
bulletin secret donné à un élu front
national lorsque on est élu soi même et
qu'on est soi-même à attacher un parti
politique donner son vote
c'est quelque part franchir une ligne
rouge et puis transgresser quelque part
aussi un habitus politique donc il y a
il ya une mécanique là dans le vote
indirects qui est beaucoup plus
difficile à acquérir pour le front
national
qu'une élection comme l'élection
présidentielle où là c'est une personne
face à un peuple est dans une condition
une conjoncture particulière on pourrait
imaginer une victoire merci beaucoup
frédéric sinclair pour toutes ces
précisions et tous les éclaircissements